-Our next guest is the Enemy--
Sorry. Oh, my God.
-God
-Our next guest
is the Emmy-nominated creato
and star of
"Billy on the Street"
and one of our favorite
guests here.
Billy Eichner,
how are you, my friend?
-Hi.
-It's so lovely to see you
How is your quarantine thus far?
-It's great.
I have a song for you.
Are you ready?
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
♪♪ Fly me to the Zoom and let
play among the stars ♪♪
♪♪ I don't remember them makin
Leno do this during SARS ♪
♪♪ In other words,
don't hold my hand ♪♪
♪♪ In other words ♪♪
Don't ever touch me!
-Wo-- That was wonderful.
-Thank you.
That's my song for you.
-That's just --
You know, it's very interestin
to live in a time
where people are not allowed
to have close contact,
because of course
you made a career
of invading people's
personal space.
-I did. In New York City, yeah
-In New York City,
of all places.
And "Billy on the Street," which
is a show I've been lucky enough
to do a few times --
-Yeah.
-This is having a resurgence
because of --
Safe to say, because of Netflix?
-Yeah, so, we did five seasons
of half-hour episodes.
And prior to that, I had don
years of YouTube videos.
And then we did five half-hour
seasons of the show.
And four of those seasons
went on Netflix in November.
So even though I'm now bac
to just doing occasional web
"Billy on the Street" videos
we don't do the half-hour
episodes anymore
because my career
took off like a rocket.
-[ Laughs ]
-But people are now discoverin
those episodes on Netflix
for the first time.
So like many things
that go on Netflix,
the show's having
this resurgence
right at a time when I cannot go
and film new videos
or new anything.
-Do you think there's --
I mean, obviously, I think
one, they're hilarious.
Two, I do think they probabl
age incredibly well.
But do you think that people are
watching it with some nostalgi
of a time where people
were just in the streets,
bumping into people
in New York City?
-Yeah, it's funny.
I never pictured that as a sho
that would ever be associate
with nostalgia or sweetness.
Although, I mean,
I grew up in New York City
You know, a lot of people
ask me how --
They're always like,
"How can you do that?"
or they're always like,
"Oh, you're fearless,"
and all these things
which always makes me laugh.
I'm so not fearless.
But the reason
I'm not scared to do that
is because New York
is my hometown.
Those streets are
where I grew up.
That's the place I'm most
comfortable, weirdly.
And so for me,
it always did have
I guess a little sweetness
underneath it.
But I never expected it
to feel nostalgic so soon.
And I think
people are watching it
because it's a little nostalgi
for the New York
that we're all used to
and also because I think
it's just very silly,
and it really is the definitio
of, you know,
we dipped our toes into social
commentary here and there,
but on the surface,
it's so absurd and so silly,
and it's a real escape
from the news every day,
which is pretty grim.
I also see a lot of families
watching it with their children,
which is not something
I ever expected.
But I'll take it. I don't care
You want to ruin your kid,
I'll gladly reap the benefits.
-Yeah, I was surprised to hear
that people were watching
with their kids, too.
And then the minute I though
about it a little bit,
I realized that my childre
would delight in watching it
You are so much fun,
and I think they would
immediately understand
the comedy of people being
interrupted by a stranger.
-Yeah, and I think, you know
I was very influenced as a kid
by Pee-wee Herman.
He was like my favorite thin
to watch as a kid.
And, you know, Pee-wee did
this thing where on one level,
he literally had a Saturda
morning show for kids like me,
but it was also
appreciated by adults.
Like, his show worked
on two different levels.
And in some ways, he was als
this human cartoon, you know
And I think that's how
children see my show.
I'm the next Pee-wee Herman,
which is what I'm trying to say,
with the exception of
masturbating in porno theaters
not that I wouldn't,
but you can't go to the porn
theaters right now, Seth.
Look at my chandelier.
It's like the gay
"Phantom of the Opera" in here
-[ Laughs ]
-It's crazy.
-I've talked to you
about this before,
but doing one of those episode
with you,
especially when we did one
together for the Emmys.
-Yes.
-Like, it's amazing
how much time
you have to put into it.
Like, the yield is lower
than people would think,
that you have to do it all day
to get, like, those 8 to 1
great moments.
And the thing
that I especially liked,
which I would not have known
is you had no --
You never had any interest
in talking to people who wer
excited to see you coming.
-No.
Well, yeah, it's --
Once in a while,
if someone recognizes me,
and, you know,
now people recognize me
more often than they did.
The nice thing
about New York is that
those streets are constantly
replenishing themselves.
There are so many people.
So we can walk up and down
the same street,
and every time we turn around,
there are new people.
And a lot of them come fro
different parts of the world
you know, or different
parts of the country,
although I think I tend
to talk to more New Yorker
than tourists.
-Yeah.
-But once in a while,
I can turn someone knowing m
into something worth using
But I'd much rather talk
to someone who doesn't know me
or doesn't know me that well
because that's part of the fun
is them experiencing it
in real time, you know?